hey guys Pete here so it's been a couple
weeks now but we're all still thinking
about the Twin Peaks finale and what I
decided to do today was put together a
list and description of all the best
theories that are out there it's not all
of them it's not completely
comprehensive but these are the ones
that had the most traction after the
finale aired and generally I think the
ones that are put together the best you
know look at the things in a more
realistic way although none of them are
perfect and I don't expect that any of
them are exactly right but it's all good
to think about so we're gonna do that
real quick I want to mention two things
the first thing is that I was really sad
to see that Harry Dean Stanton who
played collar rod passed away and I just
wanted to recognize what a great actor
he was and how much that's sad loss for
everybody and the other thing is stick
around to the end because I have some
announcements once about the book
giveaway I have going on and some other
things so try to stay with me to the
very end to find out about those so the
first theory that I'm gonna look at was
one that I don't necessarily like much
but I have seen a lot of people talking
about it and that's the idea that the
whole thing was Laura Palmer's dream in
the end of part 18 as Carrie we see
Laura scream and she does this after
hearing a faint sound of Sarah Palmer
yelling Laura which was originally from
the pilot episode Sarah Palmer was
calling after Laura this was the morning
after her death so she wasn't in her
room so the idea here is is that this
whole Richard and Linda and Kerry Page
reality is just something that Laura
came up with it's a dream and it has to
do with the trauma that she's
experienced at her father's hand
who's inhabited by Bob obviously so so
if you think about it if Cooper went
back and saved her from being murdered
then she would still you know if she
never ended up wrapped in plastic so she
would still be in that reality and this
whole thing basically comes to a
when her mother yells her name and she
wakes up alive that morning so this
obviously like most things do ties back
to the Monica Bellucci dream and this
would answer the question who is the
dreamer with Laura and that it's a story
about the terrible abuse that this girl
has gone through and in a way this is a
happy ending sort of because Cooper
saves her from being killed but in the
end of the day she would be where she
was depending on how far back you look
into it and try to make connections and
you could say that it's a different
situation but I don't know I I just I
just don't think that was what this was
about but it could be and a lot of
people like it so the next one is
probably my least favorite one and that
is that Richard is the actual dreamer so
when agent Cooper wakes up after being
with Diane when they crossed over he has
this letter waiting for him that she
laughs basically she's gone she doesn't
recognize him anymore and it's timed
Linda and it's referring to him as
Richard so we heard these things and
this is the main reason why I don't like
this so much is because the giant
mentioned Richard and Linda and going
430 miles and all this stuff early on so
there we would have to have all of that
stuff be the dream and it would be
Richards dream and depending on how you
interpret it
agent Cooper doesn't really ever exist
that's all in Richards mind so he could
be Richard could be an actual FBI agent
or he could just be some loser that has
delusions of grandeur of being an FBI
agent and that kind of is supported with
the way he acts there as I said in my
other videos I kind of think that there
was a plan in place and they followed it
and that's how they ended up there and
maybe he loses some of himself when he's
there but at the end of the day he's
still agent Cooper the names are more an
extension of the reality where they are
I don't know though I mean a lot of
people like this that like this idea and
kind of wipes out the whole reality of
everything we've seen so yeah it's there
it kind of makes sense but I'm not a big
fan of it
the next one was the most hyped but even
though the idea that the last two
episodes were intended to be synced and
watched together was largely debunked by
executive producer sabrina sutherland
the theory that started the idea was
pretty interesting I know from reading
the comments and the different tweets I
got on Twitter and replies and things
that a lot of viewers were into this
sinking idea and by thinking I mean
watching you know part 17 and part 18
putting them in a viewer lighting up the
timing and then watching them both
exactly at the same time I watched a bit
of it the first time without reading any
of the theories around it and it just
didn't seem like it's synched up at all
on purpose to me I mean of course if you
watch anything together things will work
together especially when you have an
episode like 18 where there's a lot of
downtime and a lot of long scenes but I
read the theories and they're they're
not too bad but once the Brina answered
that on her AMA on reddit that that was
not in the intention they weren't made
to be shown that way based on what her
job entails in the way that she worked
so closely with David Lynch and Mark
Frost you know I don't I just don't
think that there's anything to the idea
that they made these two parts to play
together but as mentioned the original
theory was still interesting and it was
written by a redditor Arab glad and the
idea here is that when NATO turns back
to Diane in the sheriff's department
that is her returning from the Linda and
Richard reality and when Cooper sees her
he knows that they have successfully
defeated Judy in that realm now this is
actually the end of the story and it's a
happy ending if not a complicated one
that involves a loop timeline but it
could make sense it's definitely not
perfect though as with all of these and
as it was expanded afterwards whenever
the idea of syncing the two parts
together as it was expanded I thought it
got a little less interesting there was
a lot of development in the theories
where he tried to tie
everything together where every single
thing was there for a reason
and coincided with something else in the
other part and there just got kind of
muddied into you know whatever it wasn't
it wasn't as compelling as just the idea
that we saw that they were successful
because of the reaction of Cooper and
the oddity of how that went down and I
think it's kind of interesting that part
of it so many people like the whole
thing though even though she said that
it wasn't supposed to be synced some
people believe it's still supposed to be
synced so if you want to read more about
it if you haven't looked at those posts
it's definitely worth a look and I'll
link I'll put links to all these in the
description so you can check it out
another one I mentioned before I get
into my favorite one is one that
actually came out before the finale
aired and after that other ones which
ones the one that is actually my
favorite one this is a theory that was
authored by the 1/3 and it boils down to
the idea that there's 3 separate
realities which are the normal Twin
Peaks the Red Room lodges mobs own
reality and then our own reality in our
world like reality it hinges on the idea
that the show crosses over into our
reality based on Clues like the
introduction of Eddie Vedder buy his
actual name rather than a stage name the
same MC in that part says Audrey's dance
rather than the name of the song which
is the title of the song in our world
not in the Twin Peaks television show it
has a she didn't go to the jukebox and
turn on Audrey's dance Gordon being
David Lynch and his Monica Bellucci
dream being with a real person Monica
Bellucci at a real cafe near an art
gallery where he had a real exhibition
he sees so there's there's these
different parts where things touch our
reality and so this is a clue that the
one three uses to go on to say that
Audrey sees our reality that Gordon and
his dream sees our reality and that
Monica Blues G's question can be divided
into three
things we are like the dreamer who
dreams the we in this sentence are us
the spectators who stare at the screen
and dream of Twin Peaks with David Lynch
the second one and then lives inside the
dream which is for the devoted fans
doesn't feel like living inside a dream
called Twin Peaks that we spend the rest
of our days glazed with dreamy eyes and
do not know what to do with ourselves
until the next part arrives and then
three but who is the dreamer and that of
course are you knows us the series is
taking place in our collaborative dream
according to this guy when Peaks itself
constitutes one of the main teams this
season the series is a Tulpa the
imaginary creation of us all so this is
kind of similar to what I was talking
about in my personal experience with it
so I can relate to where he's going with
this but it's still not exactly you know
the problem I have with my own
description of that is that's my
experience based on the way I felt and
what I think that we all have as common
feelings in relation to the show which
is great but I think that one of the
things that we have to keep in mind
under the surfaces is that there was an
actual story David Lynch and Mark Frost
sat down and wrote 18 episodes or they
wrote a script that became 18 episodes
so there was underlying themes that they
touched on and fleshed out during the
thing so you have like the the emotional
side of our reaction but then you also
have like what were they actually trying
to show us all the while keeping it very
open-ended so that we could make our own
you know we could draw our own
conclusions and so that brings us to the
final theory and I've tend to prefer
this to the others like I said none of
these are perfect but this one is more
from a storytelling perspective which is
you know sort of beyond my scope I've
never been a writer I don't never never
metacritic to be honest I'm just a fan
and someone who appreciates art in this
case you know so this guy David Auerbach
he wrote a post that's really kind of
in-depth I originally came across it
because I saw Kyle MacLachlan had you
know he did a quote retweet on Twitter
saying that it had some interesting
ideas so of course I clicked through it
many other people read it as well and
they brought it up to me as being pretty
good so it starts out with the idea that
the theories author had was that Twin
Peaks the return went far deeper than
the original series before the finale
came out he expected that the new season
would be about Twin Peaks not the town
but the show itself in other words the
show would wrap itself around the old
show rather than continuing the actual
plot and like I said this theory is
pretty involved but I'll do my best to
simplify things and I'll tell you that
what grabs me is that it sort of expands
on the idea I had based on my feelings
of growing older and nostalgia and the
fact that you can't go back and change
things and it puts it into the words of
a writer rather than a fan does that
make sense so so he talks about how this
is the best surmise of the kind of
submerged material Lynch built episode
18 on top of and basically how they got
from the script into the actual thing
that we saw on screen and the the main
thing here is that the alternate world
that we see Richard and Linda in was not
created by Judy herself but by the white
lodge as a trap for Judy and this starts
to make a lot of sense because if Judy
had set up that alternate dimension that
we see coop go into she did a pretty bad
job you know what I mean like it's it
doesn't seem in line with nobody's
tricked except for Laura which has been
there for a long time so she might have
experienced the same thing that Cooper
did which was she forgot herself while
she was there and
underlying important part here is that
evil coupe and Bob are not the primary
antagonists of season 3 judy is and we
see judy represented or we actually see
her in the flesh as the experiment the
mother the bug symbols jeffrey says that
according to the author here we see the
jumping man where his face goes back and
forth to Sarah Palmer the ship the
chiffons the tremens we have all this
stuff that kind of leads us back to that
idea that it is actually Judy that's the
bad guy not evil coupe and it kind of
makes sense because how easily evil
coupe was defeated whenever it came down
to his part being over Cooper has some
long-standing plan to deal with Judy
that we know about through Gordon and it
appears that the giant slash fireman's
in on this as well and the other thing
to keep in mind is is that the black
collage entities including Judy are
attracted to pain and sorrow also known
as garment Basia
and they consumed it plus electricity is
a fundamental energy like fire which
leads back to hawk and what he told
Frank Truman so the idea is is that the
White Lodge and there are hints of this
because and I talked about this in my 10
Things video for part 18 but there are
hints about this based on what he should
what the giant shows Andy and the fact
that he tells Cooper to remember the
plan basically by saying Richard and
Linda 432 birds with one stone so the
really simplified version is is that the
giant created this place he actually
puts Laura into it and Laura herself
attracts Judy into that dimension the
idea being that they want Judy over
there so they can destroy her because
destroying her in our dimension or our
reality might just destroy the whole
thing so if they set up this pocket
reality this pocket dimension then they
can destroy her there
and all will be well in our regular
world so it's gonna be a sacrifice as
you know basically a suicide mission
probably for Cooper and for Laura who
becomes you know Cooper becomes Richard
Diane becomes Linda who we don't know
where she goes other than she leaves
Cooper and we have Laura turning into
Carrie Paige and barely remembering who
she was and maybe not remembering that
and probably collecting a lot of Garmin
beau Zia because the dead person in her
living room shows that she's probably
still suffering just in a different way
and we see that the telephone poles
outside her place that could be a way
that judy is attracted or travels back
and forth to collect this pain and
sorrow we see the white horse which is a
reminder of Judy as well so there is a
lot of stuff and I don't want to talk
about this for 20 minutes so I'll let
you check the link in the description
I'll put all of them in there and you
guys can decide what you think but I
think this makes the most sense to me
because it takes the emotion of it away
and looks at it from a storytelling
perspective which there's a lot of stuff
here that talks about hawks map there's
a lot of stuff here that talks about
other events related to the lodges and
their collection of Garmin Basia so I
don't know out of all of them it seems
the most likely to me but I'm really
interested to see what you guys think so
as mentioned I still have a book
giveaway going on in my patreon we're
gonna get the winner anyone who joins
signs up donates any amount if you're
active at the 31st of October when the
books released I'll pick one of those
names out of a hat and I'll send the
book to you we're gonna cover that when
the book comes out because it should be
really interesting and bring up all
kinds of new information and the other
thing I wanted to announce based on
patreon is it seems like everybody's
interested in going back into the
original series so what I'm gonna plan
doing is I'm gonna do season 1 I'm gonna
start there and we'll see how it goes
based on the signups I have over there
now I can afford to take a few days a
month to work on that stuff and not have
to worry about chasing views for
anything else so we'll do that see how
it goes and if more people sign up we
can get through it faster it just
depends on what else is going on because
I do have other you know shows that I'm
gonna be doing as well so there's that
come over if you want to learn more
about it please like this video if you
enjoyed it make sure you subscribe if
you haven't already set up notifications
mr. robot seasons coming new Twin Peaks
stuff will be coming and I'll be
continuing with my Game of Thrones stuff
too I have a whole series I've been
working on there so
set up your notifications so you find
out when they come out one other thing I
want to mention is that they did
announce that the DVD sets coming out
for season 3 in December but the
announcement came without an actual
product link or anything yet that you
can look at so as soon as that comes out
I'll make sure that I add that in with
the description in the other area where
you can get like the final dossier
pre-order and the older stuff and
everything else so that'll be coming
asap follow me on Twitter you can talk
to me over there on my Facebook or
Instagram and thanks for watching guys
I'll talk to you soon